hello my name is sofia boutella and
apparently i'm gonna show you the last
thing on my phone you asked for it
caring is creepy by the shins do you
know it you're nodding
you told you know it Conan I saw him
yesterday for the first time I didn't
expect him to see him on stage Zak sent
me a video this morning this is bane
this is also there was one room in there
this guys having fit on the floor
this guy's haha just get just said that
he killed this is a Ghostbuster dudes to
Zack and Simon and I said geekland
talking about this video
Zack wrote back love you guys and Simon
just gave smiley kisses they're the best
the kiss symbol or this guy here you
have the little kiss face you have the
kiss mouth you have the Star Trek here
and you have the spaceship which I like
to put the little poop I like him I like
that guy and I like this guy a lot
show me your emoji I tell you who you
are I was watching clips of Carrie the
original and when she comes out of the
of prom and she's pissed off there she
is but that was your inspiration in the
role of Jayla no no not Jayla for
someone else till yesterday I put that
video of me and the boys he just gave
her a hard time and then I pushed this
one right before it's like maniax
taken
you know this is how I'm happy when I
when I wake up in the morning get out of
bed to say this warp-speed make all that
sort of language that I had no idea what
it meant unfortunately but now I do I
know all the little tricks and little
slogans and I can say beam me up and all
that yeah